hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is a little story about how i've managed
my footage over the years so i'm a
youtuber obviously and in the very
beginning most of those early videos
were super simple i would literally just
hit the record button and then when i'm
done hit stop and then upload that video
file
all right welcome to my first video
there was no editing no extra files none
of that i could just keep the file in a
folder on my desktop a couple of
megabytes upload it to youtube and then
share it with the world and then it got
a little more intricate i got a camera i
got editing software and i started
actually stitching together a bunch of
different clips and then i uploaded that
final video file to youtube
and then i just deleted all the raw
footage and all the way up to the
beginning of last year through all the
camera upgrades and all the evolution of
how i made videos i've always put
everything together uploaded the final
video then deleted the footage just
keeping the final video file and that
was actually fine because anytime i
needed to go back and get some previous
footage i could just grab it from that
final video file and that was fine with
me
but now it's 2017 and we're not just
shooting 1080p and 4k video files
anymore we're shooting 5k 6k 8k video
files to the point where if i want to go
back and use them i'm not getting the
full quality out of it so if i want to
go back and use clips from older videos
i'm grabbing a 4k version of something
that was originally shot in raw 8k which
isn't the end of the world or anything
but imagine in a couple of years having
the full 8k clips would be able to
breathe new life into them on new
platforms so late last year in 2016 i
decided i'm not going to delete all the
raw video files anymore i'm going to
keep everything or everything that's
useful so all the high resolution videos
everything so that it can be manipulated
again and shared later without losing
any quality and to do that i would need
a lot of storage the average one minute
8k video file coming off this helium
sensor at eight to one compression is
about depending on what's in it about 10
to 12 or 15 gigs so to put in
perspective that casey studio tour that
video shoot we did all the videos we got
totaled about a terabyte i understand
it's completely overkill for youtube in
2017 but again think of youtube in 2025
2030. so a couple months ago i got this
thing this is the promise pegasus ii
it's a 48 terabyte thunderbolt 3 raid
array and i started keeping all the
original footage and media on this along
with the final video file for every
project and to me and a lot of people
i'm sure that's a perfectly good
solution for a long time huge amount of
storage locally attached fast really
quiet sits right on your desk you can
edit off it it's great but if you do the
math at around a half a terabyte per
project that's less than 100 videos
before it's full so that's where linus
from linus tech tips and seagate and 45
drives and unraid come into play this is
a 10 terabyte hard drive seriously 10
terabytes in the palm of my hand this
was literally a fantasy a couple of
years ago now it's real and this is
what's called a stornator av15 by 45
drives this is a high capacity storage
server with 15 drive bays and yet still
small enough that you can put it right
next to your desk it's about the same
size as a regular pc it has a xenon cpu
inside eight gigs of ram a 650 watt
power supply and a 10 gigabit ethernet
connection and has all these fans in
here but when they're running they're
pretty quiet so barely audible from like
10 feet away so linus brings this thing
over and then basically starts handing
me these drives 10 terabytes 10
terabytes 10 terabytes 10 more terabytes
and we start populating the storinator
with these drives not gonna lie it was
really fun to add them in he's got this
he's got this he slides it into the rail
he aligns it with the bottom rail he
makes a slight adjustment
and it's in
so we get to seven drives of the 15
slots because the rest of them were
actually delayed because of shipping but
a couple days later i get the rest of
the drives and install them myself
bam 10 terabytes 10 terabytes 10
terabytes and just like that the 140
terabyte raid array is up and online 15
10 terabyte drives one for redundancy a
super secure backup now for all the raw
footage i shoot from here on out so
linus what are some of the advantages of
the setup we're looking at tell me about
it 22 seconds this guy gives me but i'm
gonna do my best this is a fantastic nas
that i flew out here to deliver for the
consumption of the one and only mkbhd
and it's pretty flipping awesome it's
built by 45 drives in a custom enclosure
using server grade hardware like the
super micro motherboard that has 10
gigabit network speeds so if he wants to
be able to dump footage on here super
fast
then that's going to be a thing and
we've gone ahead and equipped it with 15
some of them are still in the mail
15 of seagate's ironwolf pro naz hard
drive so these are special because they
have a five year warranty they're rated
at 300 terabytes of yearly data or
something stupid like that and they
include data recovery service within the
warranty period so that's really special
because we're running them on unraid
which means that because we're not
striping the data the odds of recovering
our data fully in the event of a
catastrophic failure where multiple
drives die
is actually much better other benefits
of unraid though i'm not 100 sure how
he's going to use them are things like
being able to run a plex server
yeah i'm getting a no okay uh being able
to run windows in a virtual machine i'm
getting a no um
being able to add high-speed ssd caching
for multiple people to work off it if
you expand the team i'm getting the nod
yes okay i'm on a roll here uh how about
choosing things to back up to cloud
storage like dropbox
getting the nod yes okay so it can do
all that crap so this is pretty much the
only way to have more than 100 terabytes
of storage easily accessible in one
place at least right now with current
drive densities maybe that'll change in
a couple years maybe we'll have some
crazy 50 terabyte sd cards or something
like that but until then this is what
that looks like and i think it'll be a
pretty fresh start for starting to keep
everything combine that with the pretty
fresh looking front plate from 45 drives
and uh the sweet little chassis we have
it in the airy server case i think
that's a pretty solid start as a little
little piece in the studio too so that's
pretty much it thank you for watching i
hope you enjoyed maybe you learned
something there'll be links in the
description below if you have any
questions about any of this stuff but
i'll hang out in the comments section
too and answer any questions you might
have thank you for watching
talk to you guys the next one
peace
[Music]